(Música)
(Aplausos)
Hola a todos. Soy Sirena.
Tengo 11 años y soy de Connecticut.
(Aplausos)
Bueno, realmente no estoy segura de por qué estoy aquí.
(Risas)
Quiero decir ¿qué tiene que ver ésto
con la tecnología, el entretenimiento y el diseño?
Bueno, sé que mi iPod, mi móvil y mi computadora son tecnología
pero ésto no tiene nada que ver con ello.
Así que hice una pequeña investigación al respecto.
Bueno, ésto es lo que encontré.
Por supuesto, espero poder recordarlo.
El violín es básicamente una caja de madera
y cuatro cuerdas principales.
Al tocar la cuerda, ésta vibra y produce una onda sonora.
El sonido atraviesa una pieza de madera llamada puente
y baja hasta la caja de madera y se amplifica
pero... déjenme pensar.
(Risas)
Muy bien. Por otro lado
al mover el dedo sobre el diapasón
cambia la longitud de la cuerda
lo que cambia la frecuencia de la onda sonora.
¡Oh Dios mío!
(Risas)
Muy bien. Esto es algo tecnológico
pero lo llamo tecnología del siglo XVI.
Pero de hecho, lo más fascinante que encontré
fue que el sistema de sonido
o de transmisión de onda hoy en día
están fundados básicamente en el mismo principio
de producir y proyectar el sonido.
¿No es genial?
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Diseño. Me encanta su diseño.
Recuerdo cuando era pequeña
mi mamá me preguntó,
¿quieres tocar el violín o el piano?
Eché un vistazo a ese monstruo gigante
y me dije a mí misma:
no voy a encadenarme a esa banca
todo el día.
Éste es pequeño y ligero.
Puedo tocar parada, sentada o caminando.
Y ¿saben qué?
Lo mejor de todo es que si no quiero practicar
puedo esconderlo.
(Risas)
El violín es hermoso.
Algunos dicen que tiene la forma de una mujer,
puede gustarles o no, pero
ha tenido este diseño por más de 400 años,
a diferencia de las cosas modernas que fácilmente lucen obsoletas.
Pero creo que es muy particular y único que,
aunque todos los violines lucen iguales
no hay dos violines que suenen igual.
Incluso si los fabricó la misma persona
o si fueron basados en el mismo modelo.
Entretenimiento. Me encanta el entretenimiento
aunque de hecho, el instrumento en sí mismo
no sea muy entretenido.
Quiero decir, cuando comencé con el violín
y traté de tocarlo
en realidad estuvo muy mal porque
no sonaba del modo que le escuchaba a los otros niños
tan horrible y chirriante
así que no era para nada entretenido.
Y además, mi hermano lo encontró muy divertido.
Yuk, yuk, yuk.
(Risas)
Hace algunos años escuché un chiste acerca
del gran violinista, Jascha Heifetz.
Después del concierto del Sr. Heifetz
una señorita se acercó a hacerle un cumplido.
"Oh, Sr. Heifetz, su violín sonó magnífico esta noche."
Y el Sr. Heifetz era una persona genial
así que levantó su violín y dijo:
"Es curioso, no escucho nada."
(Risas)
Ahora me doy cuenta que, al igual que el músico,
los seres humanos tenemos una gran mente,
sensibilidad artística y habilidad
que pueden convertir la tecnología del siglo XVI
y un diseño legendario
en un entretenimiento maravilloso.
Ahora, ya se por qué estoy aquí.
(Música)
(Aplausos)
Al principio pensé que venía aquí solamente a tocar frente a ustedes
pero inesperadamente, aprendí y disfruté mucho más.
Pero... aunque algunas de las charlas fueron muy elevadas para mí.
(Risas)
Como la cuestión multidimensional.
Quiero decir, en serio, estaría feliz
si pudiera entender correctamente mis dos dimensiones en la escuela.
(Risas)
Pero de hecho, lo más impresionante para mí
es que... bueno, de hecho,
también me gustaría decir esto en nombre de todos los niños
decirles, gracias, a todos los adultos
por preocuparse mucho por nosotros
y por hacer el mundo en que estaremos mucho mejor.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Música)